salut à tous cette vidéo est sponsorisé
par personne c'est pas sponsorisé vous
le savez comme chaque année du coup au
mois de juillet pour nous c'est les
vacances du coup il n'y a pas de vidéo
ce mois ci à la place ça sera juste une
simple annonce c'est lui cède à salut si
vous avez vu la dernière vidéo du coup
vous êtes au courant maintenant on va
être en train pour les prochains mois
deux bosses et la vidéo des dix ans
puisqu'en septembre de cette année ça
fera dix ans qu'on aura commencé cette
chaîne disant qu'on vous donne une vidéo
par mois on a commencé c'était en
septembre 2009 on est en septembre 2019
bientôt donc bien il est temps pour nous
de nous pencher sur cette fameuse vidéo
des dix ans comme on se craint ce sera
peut être jamais sur la vidéo des 4
millions d'abonnés au moins on va faire
la vidéo des dix ans cette vidéo des dix
ans pour l'instant on sait pas
exactement ce que ça va être n'a pas
commencé à la beauce et en fait on va
commencer à reprendre l'écriture la
semaine prochaine et on va passer
plusieurs mois dessus
cependant ça ne veut pas dire qu'il n'y
aura pas de vidéo pendant les mois qui
suivent
mais malgré tout il y aura quand même
des jdg enfin des formats un peu plus
court c'est à dire en être à moins de
mise en scène ce sera plus facile à
faire et ça nous permettra de dégager du
temps pour produire la vidéo des dix ans
au passage je précise pour que tout soit
clair ces petites vidéos jdg même si
elles sont moins mise en scène seront
quand même sponsorisés de même que la
vidéo des dix ans pourquoi pas
simplement parce qu'on aime bien
l'argent déjà pour commencer j'ai muller
jeunes et de vieux os la première
boutique reste la même ça nous permet de
pérenniser la chaîne et ce malgré les
moult démonétisation qu'il y a en ce
moment on se donne rendez vous dans
quelques mois pour la vidéo des dix ans
de jdg et d'ici là ne ratez pas le
prochain test du grenier très bientôt
sur la chaîne wii salut
[Musique]